letzte woche haben wir bei easy germany
über das wörter gesprochen wenn ihr
dieses video nochmal sehen wollt klickt
hier oben rechts in die ecke heute
sprechen wir über wörter mit wo zum
beispiel worauf womit wofür diese wörter
mit wo bilden das gegenstück zu den da
wörtern und ihr könnt diese beiden
themen gut zusammen lernen denn sie
haben sehr viel gemeinsam
dass darüber setzt man im englischen
immer mit darüber ist erwartet damit ist
im bett und dafür ist vor ist wohingegen
übersetzt man mit watch vorüber ist
erbaut watch wofür ist vor ort und womit
ist with what da wörter benutzt man mit
werben die mit präpositionen genutzt
werden wo wörter benutzt man auch mit
werden da wörter ersetzen ein objekt in
einem satz und wo wörter ersetzen auch
ein objekt der unterschied ist dass man
da wörter in normalen haupt setzen und
nebensätzen benutzt und wo wörter
benutzt man in frage setzen hier sind
zwei beispiele
ich frage womit fährst du in die stadt
und ich antworte ich fahre mit dem bus
in die stadt
womit fragt also nach einem objekt oder
ich frage wofür interessierst du dich
und ich antworte ich interessiere mich
für philosophie wider frage ich mich
wofür nach einem objekt und ihr seht im
englischen wird es immer mit wort
übersetzt forward oder with what jetzt
haben wir noch ein paar szenen für euch
vorbereitet damit ihr dieses thema
besser versteht los geht's
man war auch tut sie wovon hast du
bauchschmerzen
hast du etwas falsches gegessen auch von
den weintrauben
ich habe alle auf einmal gegessen wofür
ist dieses schild das ist für meine demo
wofür demonstriert du für die
legalisierung von marihuana
aha und woraus ist das gemacht das ist
aus pflanzen gemacht ich demonstriere
mit pflanzen für pflanzen cool oder
womit demonstréiert janosch demonstriert
mit einem schild aus pflanzen ja muss
wonach suchst du roman ich suche immer
noch meine bringe worüber freust du dich
als ich freue mich über eine geniale
idee die ich gerade hatte und worum geht
es bei dieser genialen idee es geht um
ein neues hobby fahrrad singen worum
geht s fahrrad singen ich fahre fahrrad
und singe dabei la la la la la und wozu
machst du das wozu dazu singen und zum
fahrradfahren
ich kombiniere kunst und sport genial
oder worüber denkst du nach ich denke
über den sinn des lebens nach kari hast
du dich nie gefragt woher wir alle
kommen
doch natürlich ich komme aus münster
ascari woran glaubst du eigentlich
ich glaube an das fliegende
spaghettimonster
wenn ihr das thema jetzt noch weiter
üben möchte dann schaut doch mal in
unserer interaktiven apps ihling vorbei
den link findet ihr hier unten unter dem
video und auf siedlung könnt ihr unter
anderem die aussprache zu den einzelnen
sätzen üben ihr könnt auf die untertitel
draufklicken weitere informationen zu
grammatik erhalten und auch übungen
machen
wir freuen uns sehr wenn ihr das mal
ausprobiert und uns auch euer feedback
dazu gibt außerdem könnt ihr uns wie
immer bei instagram folgen die links
findet ihr auch hier unten
easy german abonnieren und ein mitglied
von easy german werden und wir sehen uns
nächste woche wieder hier auf den kanal
wir freuen uns auf euch und bis bald